تداول رواد مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي مقطع
فيديو لعمده لندن صادق خان وهو يرعى شخصيا
اضاءه زينه رمضان لاول مره في تاريخ
العاصمه البريطانيه استقبالا لشهر رمضان
الفضيل
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
مقطع فيديو اثارا ضجه واسعه على مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي الحديث دار بين بوتين
مع الرئيس الصيني وهو يرافقه الى سيارته
لوداعه نشاهد مدى حدث بينهما
[موسيقى]
مشهد جميل تداول رواد مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي مقطع فيديو لفتاه صغير يقيم
الصلاه في المسجد الحرام ببقيه زملائه
نتابع
[موسيقى]
وا على الافئده انه
عليه في عمل ممدده
الله اكبر الله
سمع الله لمن حمده
في اول زياره له منذ العمليه العسكريه
الروسيه في اوكرانيا تجنب الرئيس الصيني
الفنادق الاكثر فخامه لصالح فندق مملوك
للصينيين في الضواحي الا ان ذلك لم يردع
فضول الصحفيين فقد كشف مقطع فيديو متداول
على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي تسليمه كميات
كبيره من وجبات كنتاكي رغم الحراسه
المشدده
[موسيقى]
كان هذا كل شيء لليوم رمضان كريم وكل عام
وانتم بخير